[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Jörg Schönenborn herzlich willkommen
schön dass Sie dabei sind beim
Presseclub heute Mittag auf dem
Schlachtfeld in der Ukraine ist
russlands Präsident Putin in der
Defensive dafür erfindet er aber immer
neue Winkelzüge immer weiteren Bruch des
Völkerrechts überrascht den Gegner und
sorgt für Angst in der westlichen
Öffentlichkeit seit Freitag muss die
Bevölkerung in Teilen der Ostukraine
unter Zwang über einen Anschluss an
Russland abstimmen offenbar wird die
Annexion in Moskau bereits für nächste
Woche vorbereitet kein Zufall das Putin
am gleichen Tag erneut über den Einsatz
von Atomwaffen spricht ist das sein Plan
die Befreiung der Ostukraine künftig ein
Angriff auf russisches Staatsgebiet sein
soll hat er dann die Grundlage für
nukleare Schläge
unterdessen gehen die Proteste in
Russland weiter gestern gab es sie in
über 30 Städten hunderte Festnahmen wir
schalten gleich zu Beginn nach Moskau
zunächst aber freue ich mich auf die
Gäste der Sendung der Krieg eskaliert
was plant Putin herzlich Willkommen an
Sabine Adler Osteuropa Expertin beim
deutschlandfunkleiterin reporterpools
ich freue mich dass Christoph von
Marschall bei uns ist diplomatischer
Korrespondent beim Tagesspiegel Stefan
Stuchlik Westdeutscher Rundfunk ist
Korrespondent für verteidigungs- und
Sicherheitspolitik im
ARD-Hauptstadtstudio und ich begrüße
Lydia Wachs bei der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik ist sie
Expertin für
Sicherheitspolitik und Ina Ruck unsere
Korrespondentin in Moskau hat in den
letzten Tagen beobachtet welche
Reaktionen es im Land gab auf die
Einberufung von Reservisten Ina gestern
konnten wir von vielen Demonstrationen
landesweit lesen offenbar mit geringem
aus geben Sie uns einen Überblick was
ist passiert in den letzten 24 Stunden
und wir schätzen sie das ein
ich glaube das wichtigste was passiert
ist ist dass dieser Erlass Putins das
teilmobilisiert werden soll doch gezeigt
hat wie tatsächlich die Stimmung in
Russland ist dass die Umfragen die wir
da immer gesehen haben 80% unterstützen
den Krieg 70 Prozent unterstützen den
Krieg wir haben immer gesagt die sind
nicht so richtig ernst zu nehmen in
einem autoritär reagiert regierten
Regime ist das schwer zu sagen aber wir
sehen jetzt die Zahlen stimmen ganz
offensichtlich nicht wir sehen das nicht
nur deshalb weil da weniger auf die
Straße gehen die trauen sich natürlich
oft auch nicht und weil viele das Land
verlassen sondern wir hören und sehen
dass im Moment jeden Tag auf der Straße
Taxifahrer eine Apothekerin mit der ich
gestern gesprochen habe so viele Leute
die plötzlich sagen das wollen wir nicht
und jetzt sagen wir es endlich das ist
echt erstaunlich wir schätzen sie das
ein dass offenbar einige tausend junge
Männer versuchen das Land zu verlassen
um sich der einen Berufung zu entziehen
die New York Times berichtete gestern
von über 2000 Autos in der
Fahrzeugschlange an der Grenze nach
Georgien
ja ich habe einen Bekannten der dessen
Schwiegersohn da auch in dieser Schlange
stand der hat sich dann ein Klapprad
gekauft die findigen Georgier verkaufen
natürlich sofort Klappräder an der
Schlange der ist heute Nacht um 5 Uhr
rübergekommen über die Grenze es sind
tatsächlich viele das sind nicht
unbedingt alles Kriegsgegner das sind
aber alles Menschen die nicht in diesen
Krieg ziehen wollen weil das ganze ja
auch sehr hasslich passiert da wird
jetzt hastig rekrutiert und mobil
gemacht niemand weiß so richtig genau
wer da eigentlich gezogen wird es werden
schon Leute wieder zurückgeschickt weil
man die falschen gezogen hat das alles
ist ich will es jetzt nicht nennen
Abstimmung mit den Füßen dazu ist die
Bewegung nicht groß genug aber das ist
doch eine sehr deutliche Ansage auch an
Putin wer da eigentlich noch hinter sind
hinter ihm steht und das und bereit ist
auch für ihn und seine Ziele in den
Krieg zu ziehen verrückt der Krieg
dauert sieben Monate menschenverachtende
Angriffe auf Städte wir haben die Bilder
aus Butcher gesehen grausame Bilder da
hat sich in Russland wenig gelegt warum
gerade jetzt was ist diese Woche
passiert
das was wir über diesen Krieg sehen im
westlichen Zeitungen lesen im Fernsehen
sehen ist nicht das was man hier sieht
man muss hier einige Anstrengungen
unternehmen um tatsächlich dieselben
Informationen zu bekommen man braucht
zum Beispiel eine eine
internetumgehungsleitung eine
vpn-leitung um gesperrte Webseiten zu
lesen das was die Menschen hier im
Fernsehen erfahren und in den staatlich
kontrollierten Medien und das sind ja
fast alle erfahren ist ein völlig
anderes Bild dieses Kriegs der ja nicht
mal Krieg heißt bislang er heißt immer
noch spezialoperationen zur Befreiung
des dornbuz wenn ich den Leuten erzähle
dass ich zu Kriegsbeginn im Land war und
dass ich in der Nacht Bomben auf Kiew
gehört habe dann glauben die mir nicht
dann sagen die wir befreien den Don Bass
also das muss man immer dazu sehen dass
wirklich die breite Masse der Menschen
vor allem die die auf dem Land leben gar
nicht wissen was da eigentlich genau
passiert in der Ukraine deshalb bislang
auch so wenig Widerstand und dazu kommt
dass man das hier einfach auch nicht
macht es gibt keine Tradition des
Widerstand Ina vielen Dank alles Gute
nach Moskau Frau Adler helfen sie mir
und unserem Publikum einzuordnen 2
Schritte von Symbolik in dieser Woche
das eine wir haben gerade drüber
gesprochen die Einberufungen von
Reservisten das andere ich habe es
eingangs erwähnt Abstimmungen unter
Zwang in den östlichen bieten der
Ukraine auch im Süden offenbar mit dem
Ziel diese Gebiete an Russland
anzuschließen was hat das größere
Gewicht was ist der gamechanger in
diesem Krieg
auf jeden Fall politisch wichtiger und
verändernder sind die Referenten
sie sind in ihrer Durchführung natürlich
nur scheinreferenten pseudo Fake was
auch immer jedenfalls ist es keine
demokratische Abstimmung wenn man sich
das vorstellt wie das verläuft im
Einzelnen dass eine mehrköpfige
Kommission da ein Hausfluren vor den
Wohnungen sitzt das auf Listen
eingetragen wird mit welcher Familie hat
man es zu tun dass Stimmzettel dann
abgeworfen werden also in diese in diese
Urnen die durchsichtig die durchsichtig
sind was der Transparenz suggerieren
soll aber wenn dafür eine gesamte
Familie zum Beispiel abgestimmt wird und
nicht jeder einzelne abstimmt also bei
oder das ganze in Bussen stattfindet man
muss sich mit diesen Einzelheiten glaube
ich überhaupt nicht aufhalten und man
muss sich auch nicht über diese ist das
jetzt dem romantisch ist das jetzt fair
natürlich alles nein das ist es alles
nicht aber warum wird es gemacht warum
findet das ganze statt
dass es geht um um das Schaffen von
Fakten nämlich das Russland eine
Begründung hat ein Erfolg vorweisen kann
es muss sich immer irgendetwas ändern
nach sieben Monaten Krieg bis jetzt hat
sich nicht viel geändert de facto und es
muss ein Vorwand geschaffen werden warum
man mit noch größerer harte in diesen
Krieg vorgeht Herr von Marschall
gleicher Einschätzung die
scheinabstimmungen haben das größere
Gewicht verändert mehr ich würde vor
allem sagen beides sind keine
gamechanger sondern es sind beides
Versuche von Putin Einfluss aus also den
Eindruck von Einfluss der Bevölkerung zu
zeigen ist richtet sich zum Teil nach
innen zum Teil nach außen und wir
sollten vorsichtig sein mit den
Einschätzungen was es wirklich bedeutet
also die naheliegende Erklärung wenn
jetzt Putin die Duma erklärt
diese Gebiete abgestimmt die sind jetzt
Teile von Russland und dann haben wir
die große Sorge wenn die Ukraine dann
versucht diese Gebiete die ja offiziell
ukrainische Gebiete sind zurück zu
erobern hat Putin Vorwand zu sagen jetzt
setzen wir alle militärischen Kräfte ein
die wir auch bei der Verteidigung
Russlands einsetzen würden das ist ja
unsere Sorge Eskalation und wie wissen
wir darauf reagieren das ist aber gar
nicht so sicher denn zum Beispiel haben
wir im Sommer Angriffe auf die Krim
erlebt die Krim ist ja seit 2014 aus
russischer Sicht schon russisches Gebiet
und wie hat Putin reagiert gar nicht ja
also ihr lässt es offen wir sollten also
nicht vorschnell sagen das ist jetzt
wirklich etwas was substanziell die
Situation verändert sondern wir müssen
uns anschauen wir argumentiert und ob
das was er sagt mit Handlungen
übereinstimmt oder nicht deswegen wäre
ich vorsichtig und die Time
Mobilisierung ich selber bin kein
Militärexperte ich rede viel mit
Militärexperten und die überwiegende
Meinung ist doch Russland ist so des
organisiert die kriegen das gar nicht
hin und schnell wird das sowieso nichts
ändern weil es Wochen wenn nicht Monate
dauern wird bis man tausende durch die
Ausbildung gebracht hat sie ausgerüstet
und an die Front gebracht hat also ein
schneller gamechanger ist wieder das
eine noch das andere und wir sollten vor
allem sehr nüchtern und ruhig darauf
schauen was Putin sagt und was er tut
bevor wir uns sozusagen selbst davon
abschrecken dass hier eine ganz
gefährliche Eskalation droht und wir uns
besser zurückhalten sollten ich würde
gern widersprechen wenn ich darf ich
hätte die teilmobil-machungen
mittelfristig für das wesentlich
bedeutendere Element dass die beiden
Republiken dann jetzt Johannes
angeschlossen werden sollen hat Putin
bereits am 21 Februar gesagt da war der
Krieg noch gar nicht begonnen also man
kann im Prinzip auch die Überraschung
des Westens was jetzt da alles so
passiert nicht so komplett
nachvollziehen ich glaube mit dieser
teilmobil-machung hatte den Krieg jetzt
quasi zu seinem eigenen Volk gebracht
und er bringt ihnen das ist ein Punkt
der oft vergessen wird zu seinen eigenen
Völkern denn es ist ja irgendwie so der
Eindruck bei uns es gibt nur ethnische
Russen und die werden gezogen die
Hauptlast von diesen Krieg tragen im
Moment die ethnischen Minoritäten also
die Leute aus Tages dann die Leute aus
pro Jahr ziehen die Leute aus Tuwa
möglicherweise die Leute aus tatastan so
und da bekommt er wenn sie nämlich die
die Bilder sehen wo gezogen wird wo die
herkommen dann sind die nicht aus der
Umgebung von Moskau die sind nicht aus
der Umgebung von St Petersburger das
sind sehr wenige die kommen genau aus
diesen Provinzen und sollte das sage ich
jetzt mal ganz salopp schief gehen mit
der Ukraine dann hat Putin damit auch
die Axt gelegt an den Zusammenhalt der
Russischen Föderation ich glaube schon
dass das was jetzt gerade auch die
Kollegin geschildert hat im Land dass
das mittelfristig wesentlich mehr Effekt
haben wird als die Anerkennung der
Provinzen Lohans dann jetzt saporizia
und
Herzogstand komplettieren sie die Runde
jetzt bin ich gespannt auf Ihre
Einschätzung ich würde gar nicht hier
zwischen den beiden entscheiden wollen
ich würde eher den den Mittelweg wählen
und zwar würde ich sagen wir müssen das
alles in einem Kontext sehen das heißt
was Putin hier eben versucht im vor
Ortler hatte Fakten schaffen was Putin
hier versucht ist eben durch die
Annexion durch die gewaltsame Annexion
und eben scheinreferenten hier das
Territorium oder das östliche
theoretorium der Ukraine eben
einzunehmen und dann eine
Teilmobilmachung durchzuführen und damit
quasi Fakten zu schaffen die Situation
einzufrieren und zwar einfach deswegen
weil in den letzten Wochen sich die
Ukraine eben auch als sehr erfolgreich
gezeigt hat und Putin hat hier scheinbar
Sorge dass diese gegenoffensiven von
ukrainischer Seite auch weitergehen das
heißt er versucht die Situation so
einzufrieren er versucht gleichzeitig
uns hier einzuschüchtern eben durch
diese nuklearrhetorik aber ich würde
hier auch Herrn stucklix zustimmen und
zwar ist er im oder zeigt er hiermit
dass er bereit ist auch innenpolitische
Risiken einzugehen und das hat er bisher
nicht so stark getan also er hat ja
bisher versucht eben den Krieg von der
eigenen Bevölkerung abzuschirmen und das
ist jetzt ein Schritt daraus hinaus und
eben den Krieg wirklich an an die in
Russland zu bringen und nun kann sich
kein Mensch in Russland mehr davon
entziehen danke für die Abwägung ihnen
danke dass Sie in den sozialen
Netzwerken bei tagesschau.de
presseclub.de wieder so aktiv und dabei
sind schon einiges gelesen von ihren
Fragen und Anmerkungen und will das auch
nutzen dass wir die Dinge jetzt noch mal
nacheinander besprechen beginnen wir mit
diesen scheinabstimmungen mit der
Vorbereitung des Anschlusses der
Annexion eine Frage die viele Menschen
unsere Öffentlichkeit ja selbst die
Politik in Berlin beschäftigt ist in der
Tat droht jetzt ein Atomschlag ist es
zur realistischen option will Putin das
vorbereiten um im Zweifel Atomraketen
einzusetzen
also ich denke hier sind verschiedene
Punkte erst einmal wichtig zunächst ist
es so dass wir über die ganzen letzten
Monate diese nuklear Rhetorik von
russischer Seite gesehen haben und es
ist enorm verstörend und das ist enorm
verantwortungslos aber wir müssen eben
auch genau schauen was Russland was
putiniert genau tut und quasi schauen
inwiefern das mit dem einhergeht was er
sagt und zwar haben wir eben diese sehr
teilweise sehr offensiven Drohungen
gesehen aber wenn wir uns anschauen was
bisher vorbereitet wurde dann sehen wir
erstens keinerlei Vorbereitungen die
irgendwie darauf hindeuten würden dass
Russland sich hier auf ein
Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen vorbereiten
würden es ist nach wie vor so dass die
Kosten eines nukleare von Einsatzes
enorm enorm groß wären Russland würde
mit ziemlicher Sicherheit international
isoliert werden es würde eben ein Bruch
der internationalen Ordnung der
nuklearen Ordnung darstellen der Nutzen
wiederum wäre ziemlich gering denn
Nuklearwaffen kann man natürlich auch
für militärische Ziele einsetzen aber
der nutzen dabei ist nicht besonders
groß da kann man auch konventionelle
Waffen einsetzen das heißt Putin hat
auch noch andere eskalationsmittel bevor
er so einen Schritt wagen müsste mich
interessiert Radler einfach mal ihre
Einschätzung aber hören wir doch einmal
den Mann über den wir sprechen Wladimir
Putin Fernsehansprache am Mittwoch zu
genau diesen Punkt
Dankeschön
diejenigen die uns drohen sagt er
erinnere ich dass auch unser Land über
diverse zerstörungsmittel verfügt in
einzelnen Komponenten sind wir noch
moderner als die NATO wenn unsere
territoriale Einheit gefährdet ist wenn
unser Volk geschützt werden muss werden
wir sämtliche Mittel anwenden
ich plaffe nicht heißen diese letzten
Worte ist das der Bluff dass er sagt ich
bleife nicht na ja also es ist wenn man
schon dazu sagen muss dass es kein Bluff
ist dann ist es ja irgendwie schon
Eingeständnis dessen dass die Botschaft
vorher offenbar nicht angekommen ist und
das was ihr gehört haben das haben wir
ungefähr viermal gehört oder fünf mal
gehört das ist jetzt auch wirklich
tatsächlich keine neue Situation diese
Begründung für die teilmobilisierung das
war Teil der Rede für die
teilmobilisierung ist überhaupt nicht
neu
was was wieder überholt der Fall war ist
dass er einfach die Verhältnisse vom
Kopf auf die Füße umgekehrt vom von den
Füßen auf den Kopf stellt das heißt also
diese Rede war voller Lügen und wenn man
sie Satz für Satz analysieren würde
würde man keinen einzigen Satz finden
indem er nicht die Wahrheit komplett
verdreht und es gibt diese
Anpassung dass er in einer anderen
Realität lebt das könnte sein das wissen
wir nicht aber wir wissen dass die
Begründung einfach
vollkommene hirnsinne sie haben eben ja
schon angedeutet sind dann dran Herr von
Marschall also wir sind bei der Frage ob
sich die Sorge vor dem Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen diese Woche vergrößert
haben muss
ich wäre nicht so weit dass man quasi
die Sorge einfach so vom Tisch wischt
ich glaube das ist eine Diskussion die
wir in Deutschland grundsätzlich führen
sollten das ist die Diskussion die um
dieses ganze der Regierung wenn ich das
mal so sagen darf um die Waffenlieferung
steckt wir sollten uns da wirklich einen
Kopf darum machen er lebt möglicherweise
nicht in der eigenen Welt aber es ist
ein KGB-Mann wir gucken auf die
Atomwaffen es ist aber nicht gesagt dass
es möglicherweise nicht ein Unfall gibt
in atomaren Kraftwerk zum Beispiel in
saporisha das würde ich Putin ich meine
das jetzt wirklich in einem Ernst
durchaus zutrauen weil dann kann man
nämlich immer noch debattieren wer hat
was getroffen da gibt es möglicherweise
nuklearen
kleinen Unfall wie man das wie man das
so nennen würde das würde ich im
durchaus zutrauen ich glaube man sollte
nicht verengt nur auf den Nuklearwaffen
gucken nicht nur drauf gucken not locked
Arm da ist es noch überhaupt nichts
passiert sondern gucken was an möglichen
Varianten hat der Mann denn eigentlich
noch ein Köcher ich will um Gottes
Willen jetzt keine Panik schüren aber
ich finde wir sollten uns hier gerade in
Deutschland auch ernsthaft darüber
unterhalten bevor wir uns entschließen
weitere Waffen zu liefern
ja ich finde das sind wir der
Bevölkerung schuldig also das einfach
vom tischwäschen und sagen nicht ernst
nehmen so kann man damit nicht umgehen
was folgt dann daran die Ängste sind ja
da aber man das soll ein nicht davon
abhalten es genau zu analysieren und
Lydia Bax hat ja schon gesagt
militärisch macht das gar keinen Sinn
also militärisch macht der Einsatz von
Atomwaffen keinen Sinn sondern es ist
eine psychologische Waffe die uns
verunsichern soll und sie ist in einem
sie kann in einem Punkt wirklich ich
will das nur festhalten besteht darüber
also sind keine generellen und Generäle
aber
besteht darüber Einvernehmen dass es
keinen Sinn militärisch präzisieren
ernst nehmen ja aber sich einschüchtern
lassen nein es geht um die Frage also
sind wir uns einig also es ist kein
gebotenes militärisches Mittel die Frage
ist ob Putin immer nach der Logik des
Militärs handelt
einige Sachen gesehen die militärisch
wenig Sinn machen die aber ganz andere
ganz andere Zwecke verfolgen der Zweck
ist ja ein ganz anderer das soll uns
hier beeinflussen es soll uns selber
abschrecken dass wir anfangen zu
überlegen liefern wir nur die Panzer
machen wir es allein als deutsche kann
man es nur machen wenn man alle Europäer
zusammen oder müssen die Amerikaner auch
noch Panzer liefern damit sozusagen das
Risiko abgedeckt ist die Bundesregierung
verbreitet ja und ich weiß gar nicht ob
das klug ist die Behauptung Wladimir
Putin habe Scholz in einem Telefonanruf
direkt gedroht dass es sich wenn gegen
Deutschland richten würde also soweit
ich mit Atombomben und rüstungsexperten
Rede halten die fast durch die Bank
die Drohung das Putin den Westen mit
Atomwaffen angreift für völlig aus der
Welt weil das ist Selbstmord der Westen
verfügt über wesentlich härtere
vernichtungsmöglichkeiten in dem
Rückschlag also das ist eine rein
politische Frage die andere Frage ist ob
es in der Ukraine macht um wieder diese
psychologische Wirkung guck mal ich
könnte ja also die Angst bei uns zu
schüren indem er eine taktische
gefechtsweltwaffe die drei
Quadratkilometer verstrahlt aber auch
nicht die ganze Ukraine oder halt der
Atomunfall in saporishi der
herbeigeführt wird und ich glaube mein
persönliches Bild von Putin ist er ist
ein rationaler Mensch er lebt in einer
anderen Rationalität ich habe ihn bisher
nicht als Kamikaze Menschen erlebt als
Selbstmörder und das zweite oder dritte
was man noch dazu vielleicht sagen
sollte es ist ja nicht so dass egal ob
der amerikanische oder die russische
Präsident zu Hause alleine im Kämmerlein
sitzt und einen Knopf vor sich hat und
wenn er da drauf drückt fliegt irgendwas
los sondern da ist ja eine komplette
Befehlskette dahinter da müssen ja Leute
mitmachen die auch alle Angst um ihr
Leben um ihre Familien umsonst was haben
und deswegen niemand kann den deutschen
die Angst nehmen niemand kann Ihnen
sagen ich garantiere euch es wird nicht
passieren aber die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
die können wir glaube ich schon rational
durchdiskutieren wie sie sagen wir
sollten es wirklich offen diskutieren
und meine allerletzte Bemerkung
nach meinem Eindruck ich rede viel auch
mit anderen Europäern in Polen in
Großbritannien wo auch immer es wirkt
besonders in Deutschland es wird bei uns
stärker als im Baltikum in Polen die
sind näher dran die müssten jetzt
rational betrachtet eigentlich mehr
Angst davor haben als wir aber sie haben
einen anderen Umgang mit Russland und da
kann man den deutschen nur sagen wir
sind nicht alleine ja wir sind in einem
Bündnis und wenn ist das eine Drohung
die sich an dieses gesamte Bündnis
richtet und da ist dieser kanzlersatz
nicht alleine das ist wichtig das geht
nämlich in beide Richtungen wir sollen
nicht mehr machen als die anderen aber
wir können uns auch nicht durch weniger
tun als die anderen aus den Bündnis
herausziehen also wir sollten uns
absichern indem wir das sozusagen im
Dialog mit unseren Verbündeten östlich
wie westlich machen dann ist das Risiko
für uns als deutsche am aller geringsten
dann schauen wir auf das andere Thema
also ich sehe keine großen
Meinungsverschiedenheiten es
keine allzu große Sorge aber schon
Mahnungen das ernstzunehmen es gibt vor
allem jetzt noch mal von Herrn von
Marshall den Hinweis dass es auf eine
Öffentlichkeit zielt gerade in
Deutschland um Einfluss zu nehmen auf
politischer Entscheidungen dann kommen
wir zum anderen Thema zu dieser
mobilenmachung von der sie den ersten
Äußerungen schon gesagt haben ja kann
dauern liest man ja auch diese Woche
eigentlich von vielen ExpertInnen
Experten die müssen erstmal die Leute
ausbilden die Frage die ich auch bei
unserem Publikum lese hendrikulinski zum
Beispiel was heißt das denn wann kommt
dann die Angriffswelle die auf dieser
Mobilisierung fußt ist es nach dem
Winter die Frühjahrsoffensive
das ist momentan alles relativ schwer zu
sagen also in dieser Rede von Putin und
dann toll am Mittwoch oder in dieser
Ankündigung haben sie ja eben von
300.000 Soldaten oder Reservisten mit
militärischer Vorerfahrung davon haben
sie gesprochen dass diese mobilisiert
werden sollen und eben in die Ukraine
geschickt werden sollen und dass diese
auch ausgebildet werden sollen diese
Kriterien die sie da aufstellen also das
ist Reservisten sind mit militärischer
Vorerfahrung das ist keine
Wehrpflichtigen sind das ist keine
Studenten sind das scheinen sie aber gar
nicht einzuhalten denn wenn wir uns
genau das das Dekret anschauen was
welches diese diese time Mobilmachung
quasi rechtlich festsetzt dann fehlt
eben da ein Paragraph also erstens
werden da diese Kriterien nicht genannt
und zweitens fehlt ein Paragraph wo es
mittlerweile unterschiedliche auch
informationen und Berichte darüber gibt
dass eben in diesem Paragraphen drin
steht dass es sich hier um eine
wesentlich größer ist nicht
veröffentlicht worden genau er wurde
nicht veröffentlicht da wurde geschwärzt
dass es sich hier um eine wesentlich
größere Mobilisierung handelt und zwar
um an
Millionen Personen das heißt wir
sprechen hier nicht mehr von einer
kleinen thaimobil machen sondern von
einer wesentlich größeren Mobilisierung
und unterschiedliche Meldungen eben aus
Russland gibt es ja jetzt mittlerweile
schon dass unterschiedslos Menschen oder
Männer eben
mobilisiert werden und das jetzt alles
umzusetzen wird eben enorm schwierig
sein und da in der Rock ist ja auch
darauf eingegangen dass es hier schon
extrem viel Chaos gibt in Russland bei
der Umsetzung das heißt erstmal diese
Person alle zu mobilisieren sie sollen
dann ausgebildet werden wobei es jetzt
auch schon Berichte gibt dass sie nur
eine Ausbildung von zwei Wochen er
bekommen sollen was wirklich nichts ist
um um Menschen in den Kampf in den Krieg
zu schicken
das heißt sie werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich relativ bald dorthin
gebracht aber wir sollten uns hier
glaube ich keiner Illusionen hingeben
dass das dann ausgebildete
Militärangehörige sind das sind Männer
die eben aus Russland aus normalen Jobs
abgezogen wurden und in den Krieg
geschickt werden
die Grundfrage ist doch sie haben ja
darauf hingewiesen warten wir jetzt auf
eine offensive
Putin macht ja im Prinzip jetzt nichts
anderes als mein Problem zu beseitigen
nämlich irgendwie hat zu wenig Leute die
Defensive die Defensive aufzuheiten der
wird versuchen müssen ganz dringend im
Nordosten diese Front zum Stillstand zu
bringen er wird versuchen da wieder in
Graben und Stellungskrieg zu kommen wo
die Russen erfahrungsgemäß einfach
wesentlich bessere Karten haben wo diese
Leute hinkommen ist noch überhaupt nicht
ausgemacht sie haben vollständig zurecht
gesagt das herrscht vollständig ist
Chaos die Kritik geht bis hoch in die
hohen Regierungsbeamten bzw zu Margarita
simonyang also die der Chef
Propagandistin die sagt also so kann
kriegt man die Leute gar nicht ran ich
glaube nicht dass wir in den nächsten
Wochen oder Monaten jetzt sowas wie eine
große Offensive sehen werden sondern ich
glaube einfach dass es ein Umverteilung
Schema ist und der wird versuchen müssen
dringend die Front bei Vision und
kopians
Adler weiß nicht wer von ihnen das
gesagt hat es gehe eben darum
einzufrieren mit beiden Maßnahmen also
sozusagen den Verlust an Gewicht und
Stellung zu verhindern das würde
dementsprechend ich würde gerne noch
etwas anderes ergänzen nämlich das eine
ist dass eine Zahl von 300.000 genannt
wurde und es ja diese diese andere
Version gibt in der geschwärzten oder
nicht veröffentlichten
sieben in diesem Erlass dass da
eigentlich von über einer Millionen aber
Sergej Scholl guter
Verteidigungsminister hat in seiner Rede
zur Erklärung dieses Präsidenten
Erlasses von 25 Millionen Reservisten
gesprochen und das Übersetzen die Russen
natürlich sehr zurecht dass das jeden
treffen kann dass damit eben überhaupt
nicht meine Eingrenzung auf eine Million
oder 300.000 gemeint ist sondern im
Grunde genommen dem dem Einziehen von
Leuten Tür und Tor geöffnet ist und dann
das ist ein Punkt
weil es eigentlich der nächste Gedanke
ist also wir erwarten keine großen kurz
heutigen militärischen Auswirkungen wir
haben aber zu Beginn der Sendung über
die Demonstration über die Reaktion im
Land gesprochen russland hat weit über
100 Millionen Einwohner
300.000 Männer sind viele Menschen aber
so auf den ersten Blick fragt man sich
wie kann das destabilisieren wie kann es
sein dass da Putins große Macht wackelt
sie waren ja auch Korrespondentin im
Land so wie Stephan stocklick also
deshalb sie haben den Pfad ja dahin
geführt welche Wirkung auf das Land auf
die Bevölkerung kann das haben also
zunächst hat es die Wirkung dass die
Russen die Erfahrung machen diese ganze
Mobilisierung ist zu rechtlos wie alles
rechtlos ist es gibt zwar Paragraphen
wer eingezogen wird aber es hält sich ja
schon jetzt niemand daran das ist
vollkommen klar da werden schon Väter
von von vielen Kindern und eigentlich
Leute ohne wehrausbildung also ohne
kürzliche wehrausbildung und so weiter
also die ganzen eigenen Vorgaben werden
ja jetzt schon überhaupt nicht
eingehalten somit bekommt man natürlich
auch keine ausgebilde Soldaten aber vor
allem eben auch keine motivierten
Soldaten das ist das eine militärische
und im Land ist es eigentlich nichts
Neues im Land heißt es das Regime macht
mit uns was es will es erlässt
irgendwelche Gesetze die im Grunde
genommen immer anderes recht eigentlich
brechen was vorher schon mal irgendwo
anders geschrieben wurde und sie machen
mit uns was Sie wollen aber das ganze
hat nicht die Qualität immer noch nicht
und ich glaube die bekommt es auch
leider erst wenn die Sage nach Hause
kommen wenn die Toten wenn es Tote gibt
wenn die Toten tatsächlich in den
Petersburger und moskauerfamilien sind
dann kommt der Krieg in Russland an das
wünscht man natürlich niemanden aber ich
glaube erst dann gibt es tatsächlich so
etwas wie ein Aufwachen ich interessiert
auch von diese politische und
psychologische Seite denn was da auf dem
Papier aufgeschrieben wird ich meine
fantasiearmeen die man sich hochrechnet
weil es bevölkerungspotenzial gibt damit
haben schon viele Diktatur angearbeitet
die existieren ja deswegen nicht auf
Papier und erstens ist es angekommen ist
sehr unpopulär für die Mittelschicht in
den Großstädten ist ja schon
angesprochen worden dass die eigenen
Söhne da eingezogen werden sollen es ist
nicht populär weil die russische Armee
im Moment eine Armee ist die im Ruf
steht den Krieg zu verlieren sie gehen
ja auch nicht im Sport am liebsten in
das Stadion wurde Absteiger gerade
spielt nicht also dann gehen Sie lieber
nicht hin nicht also das gibt sehr
wenige die sagen dann ist es umso
nötiger dass ich meine staatsbürgerliche
Pflicht erfülle und die praktische Seite
ist es fehlt doch nicht nur jetzt an
Mann an der Front es fehlt ja auch an
Offizieren um die auszubilden und um
wenn neue Einheiten aufgestellt worden
sind um das Offiziere dieser Einheiten
auch führen und sie müssen sie mit
Waffen ausrüsten und die russische Armee
so weit wir wissen ist ja auch bei
vielen nachschubfragen auf westliche
Technologie angewiesen die brauchen zum
Beispiel Chips damit sie gelenkte Waffen
überhaupt die können die gar nicht mehr
bauen also ich will jetzt nicht sagen
dass es alles kurz vorm Zusammenbruch
und der Krieg ist schon gewonnen dass
wir eine völlig falsche und sehr
gefährliche
Übersprungshandlung aber wir sollten uns
Russland deutlich größer reden als es
ist und in bisherigen sieben Monaten
haben sie vor allem gezeigt dass sie
desorganisiert sind dass sie es
organisatorisch nicht hinbekommen und in
Russland haben ja auch die unteren
Ebenen keine Eigeninitiative um
sozusagen wenn die Führung versagt und
dann selber irgendwas zu entscheiden die
sitzen da und warten auf ihre Befehle
die nicht kommen und das macht die
Erfolglosigkeit aberwachs und Herr
stocklig sind noch dran zu der Frage und
ich gebe ihnen Petra Heinze und
heckelsfrage mit warum gibt es
eigentlich nicht erkennbar im Umfeld von
Putin Gegner in der militärischen Spitze
Frau wax Unterstock
das ist natürlich sehr schwer zu
beantworten weil wir nicht genau wissen
wie das Umfeld von Putin jetzt genau
gerade agiert wir haben da natürlich
keine direkten Informationen rein von
daher ist das schwer schwer zu
beantworten aber diese ganze
Entscheidung ist
militärisch also es gab jetzt
mittlerweile unterschiedliche Berichte
dass es immer mehr auch Befehlshaber
gibt die zum Beispiel dafür eingetreten
sind dass man zum Beispiel aus der
Region stärker zurücktritt und so
das heißt dass ich hier aber Putin immer
stärker auch eben in militärische
Entscheidungen einmischt das heißt dass
er so quasi Mikromanagement im Krieg
selber
durchführt und dadurch sicherlich auch
nicht zu besonders großen militärischen
Erfolgen dazu beiträgt weil er eben
überhaupt nicht das genaue Lagebild hat
das heißt es ist es gibt hier Probleme
an an vielen Ecken und Enden und eben
Christoph von Marschall ist darauf
eingegangen es gibt nicht genug
Ausrüstung es gibt nicht Equipment
Nachschub gestaltet sich als schwierig
logistisch ist es schwierig Moral ist
extrem schlecht und sie wird tendenziell
immer schlechter ich meine wenn man
jetzt eben nicht ausgebildete Menschen
in den Krieg schickt die keine Ahnung
davon haben wie sie hier kämpfen sollen
und da auch gar kein Interesse daran
haben wie wie soll man denn wie soll man
denn da eine kampforal entstehen die die
Ukraine ja ganz offensichtlich hat
ich breites im Prinzip schon mal nicht
für beruhigend wenn er seinen
stellvertretenden Verteidigungsminister
ich glaube Bulgari ist der Mann entlässt
das weiß genau darauf hin dass er sich
selber mehr und mehr militärische
Details einmischt aber der
hauptpsychologische Umschlagpunkt ist
das Putin ja eigentlich immer sein Volk
erklärt hat dass diese gesamte
spezialabbruch Operationen im Westen
dass die im Prinzip kostenfrei zu haben
ist das überlassen wir den Profis das
macht das Militär
übrigens sind 300.000 Mann gar nicht so
wenig das gesamte die gesamte russische
Armee hat eine Million das heißt wir
sprechen quasi über ein Drittel was er
jetzt zusätzlich offiziell auf dem
Papier ausheben will und jetzt kommen
aber Kosten auf ihn zu denn jetzt kommen
die normalen russischen
meistens sind das Männer ich höre auch
irgendwie von zwangsweise Einziehung von
Krankenschwestern und so weiter aber
sind zum großen Teil Männer das heißt
jetzt kommen Kosten auf das Land zu es
kommen Kosten auf das Land zu
menschlicher Kosten es kommen enorme
Kosten darauf zu sie müssen sich ja mal
vorstellen was das das Land bedeutet
diese Leute die ja da gerade einzieht
sind für den normalen Alltag nicht
brauchbar es werden Fluglinien werden
eingestellt ja man kommt nicht mehr von
A nach B weil die Leute nicht mehr raus
sollen auf der anderen Seite werden
Leute abgezogen wie zum Beispiel die
Piloten von Aeroflot die ja alle
militärische Grundausbildung haben
zumindest die älteren von ihnen das
heißt das wird erhebliche Auswirkungen
haben auf den kompletten normalen Alltag
in Russland und das sind die Kosten die
ja glaube ich noch nicht so richtig
kalkulieren kann ich würde jetzt gerne
die Perspektive um 180 Grad drehen wir
haben jetzt über den innenblick in
Russland gesprochen ich sehe viele
Fragen viele Anmerkungen die Empörung
ausdrücken dass wir die Welt die
Vereinten Nationen zuschauen müssen wie
kann es sein dass die UN nur zuschauen
wenn Menschen in Russland verhaftet
werden die gegen Krieg und Frieden
demonstrieren wann ist der Punkt
erreicht wo er vor das Kriegsgericht in
Den Haag gestellt werden kann das drückt
ja ein Gefühl von Empörung und Ohnmacht
aus
was ist aus der Perspektive des Westens
der die Ukraine unterstützt jetzt der
nächste Schritt für Adler einfach mal
schauen ich glaube wir sind in der
relativ hilflosen Situation dass die
unreform seit Jahrzehnten
immer wieder verschoben wurde dass es
dass wir überhaupt nicht vorankommen
dass die Vergrößerung wird ihm das Veto
im nato-sicherheitsrat also diese
Forderung die jetzt ja das erste Mal
überhaupt erhoben wurde und und
natürlich ist diese Sicherheitsrat mit
diesen fünf ständigen Mitgliedern per se
ja schon so ein zementiert und so
eingemauert dass von dort aus überhaupt
keine Reform oder ein Eingeständnis oder
ein eine Bewegung Russland daraus zu
werfen irgendwie erwartbar wäre das wird
nicht kommen dann müssen da müssen sich
tatsächlich die Führer der
Weltgemeinschaft zusammentun und eine
sehr schnelle Entscheidung treffen die
nicht unmöglich die muss man politisch
gebeugt sein das ist das eine und das
andere ist eher jemand wie Putin vor ein
Kriegsverbrecher Tribunal kommt muss er
erst mal von seinem Land ausgeliefert
werden und Abwesenheit verhandeln könnte
in Abwesenheit verhandelt werden wird in
aller Regel dann begonnen wenn man sieht
dass das eigene Land gar nicht damit
umgeht mit diesen Verbrechen das ist im
Moment nicht absehbar und vielleicht
noch ein ganz kleiner Nachtrag zu dem
was wir gerade eben noch verhandelt
haben
die dass das wirklich Fatale an Russland
ist dass es keine Achtung vor dem Leben
der eigenen Bürger hat und dieser
Begriff Kanonenfutter der in diesen
Tagen so häufig viel ist eben
tatsächlich im Unterschied zur Ukraine
zu vielen vielen anderen Playern in
diesem Konflikt es ist der russischen
Führung egal wie viele Menschen sterben
ihre also ihre Menschen stefanmarscher
in welche konkreten politischen Schritte
wird Empörung jetzt umgewöhnst oder
sollte werden ja ich glaube wir müssen
diese Empörung auf das sozusagen
realistische Maß was möglich ist
zurückführen also ich verstehe diese
Bedürfnisse die haben wir alle wir
wünschen uns Gerechtigkeit und als vor
zwei Wochen diesen enormen ukrainischen
Erfolge unerwartet schnell eintrafen
sein oh Jubel Jubel Jubel nicht ganz
toll jetzt geschieht das was wir wollen
der ungerechtfertigte Angriffskrieg wird
gestoppt die können sogar zurückerobern
und jetzt lernen wir auf einmal das ist
alles nicht so einfach je größer die
Erfolge sind das ist das Paradoxe umso
schwieriger und gefährlicher wird die
Situation weil Putin natürlich nicht
sagt oh ihr habt Erfolge dann weiß ich
zurück sondern er versucht halt gegen zu
eskalieren was die UN betrifft es ist
ein unvollkommenes System ich sehe das
alles nicht dass Russland sein behetto
geraubt bekommt wir dann machen wir uns
ja auch was vor wie eigentlich die
Stimmungen in der Welt verteilt sind es
ist doch nicht so dass die ganze Welt
geeint gegen Putin steht der hat ja eine
ganze Menge
Verbündete oder zumindest Länder die
Verständnis zeigen und sagen ja der
Westen ist doch Schuld mit seinen
Sanktionen dass auf einmal das Getreide
in Afrika fehlt Indien größte Demokratie
der Welt nutzt die Gelegenheit sehr
gerne um möglichst billig an russische
Energie ranzukommen und zum Teil an uns
weiter zu verkaufen mit Prophet nicht
also das ist nicht so das ist diese
wunderbare Welt gibt die eine
Rechtsordnung hat und wenn einer dagegen
verstößt sind irgendwie die anderen 199
von den 200 Staaten dagegen so simpel
ist es nicht und das das sollten wir
auch einfach sehr sehr nüchtern sein in
dem was wir erwarten der Großteil der
Welt sagt das hat mit uns nichts zu tun
das ist nicht unser Krieg das ist euer
Krieg in Europa der besten gegen
Russland und umgekehrt und China wird
sich irgendwie dazu verhalten aber
deswegen auch hatten wir ja vorhin schon
bestimmte Dinge kann Putin nicht tun
weil er dann diese Unterstützung
riskieren würde Stichwort
Atomwaffeneinsatz dann hat er wirklich
verspielte Interessen ist entschuldigung
dass ich reingehe der besten ist zu spät
dran das ist ein Moment dass man nicht
unterschätzen darf man hätte reagieren
müssen meine Sachen 2008 aber spätestens
2014 hätte man sich wirklich überlegen
müssen was mir internationalen Gremien
mit einem Land tut was ein anderes Land
überfällt auch das war ja damals
Tatsache die krimüberfallen hat dann die
aus Ukraine besetzt hat wir haben ich
erinnere noch an die deutsche
Bundesregierung die 2014 dann gesagt hat
gut dann machen wir Nord Stream 2 und
2015 heißt dann die ersten Massaker in
der OST Ukraine loslegen haben wir
unsere Gasspeicher verkauft das ist
möglicherweise ein bisschen
dilettantisches Handel der
Bundesregierung aber man hätte sich
natürlich in der EU in der NATO gucken
Sie sich mal an wie spät denn diese
nato-reform in madrida Gipfel und so
weiter gekommen sind wesentlich früher
darüber im Kopf machen müssen ich habe
zwei Fragen noch im Kopf die Sendezeit
lässt aber nur Raum für eine
ich stelle mal die Frage zurück jetzt
dann nicht erst recht Kampfpanzer und
schnell haben wir letzte Woche viel
darüber diskutiert packe ich mal ein
die andere Frage ist ja die Sehnsucht
nach Verhandlungen nach zumindest der
Beendigung des militärischen Tuns
sind Verhandlungen in der letzten Woche
ins unerreichbare gerückt
ich würde schon sagen dass wir jetzt mit
Putins Ankündigung mit der teilmobil
machen mit eben dieser Annexion mit den
Scheinen Referenten wir sehen hier
gerade das Putin gar keine Interesse an
Verhandlungen hat und auch nicht an
einem schnellen Ende dieses Krieges
zumindest solange es nicht zu den
eigenen Gunsten endet das heißt Putin
zeigt hier dass er erhöhte Risiken eben
wir sprachen über die innenpolitischen
Risiken bereites einzugehen um diesen
Krieg weiterzuführen und um eben jetzt
erstmal östliche Gebiete in der Ukraine
einzunehmen aber dieser Generalplan dass
das Putin da am Ende die die Ukraine
einnehmen will daran hat sich auch
nichts verändert das heißt wir sehen
hier von von russischer Seite kein
Interesse an Verhandlungen das heißt ich
denke aus aus deutscher Sicht können wir
jetzt gerade nur die Ukraine
unterstützen und das sollten wir auch
denn wir haben auch neben den
Gräueltaten die wir da sehen wo wir
nicht einfach dazu schauen können
sondern wir haben auch ein strategisches
Interesse daran das Putin in diesem
Krieg nicht gewinnen kann denn das würde
gesamte europäische sicherheitsordnung
extrem bedrohen und destabilisieren das
heißt wir haben auch in Deutschland
einen strategisches Interesse daran hier
die Ukraine zu unterstützen und das ist
gerade das einzige was wir tun können
das heißt das Ziel sollte jetzt eben
sein dass wir die Ukraine dahin gehen
unterstützen dass eben ihre
Verhandlungsposition dann sollte es
irgendwann zu Verhandlungen kommen denn
es wird womöglich vermutlich irgendwann
zu Verhandlungen kommen dass dann die
die Verhandlungsposition der Ukraine am
besten ist und das entscheidet eben was
auf dem was auf dem schachtfeld passiert
Verhandlungen jetzt in sehr weiter Ferne
in sehr weiter Ferne wir wünschen uns
das natürlich auch damit nicht möglichst
noch mehr Menschen sterben nicht aber
der Wunsch allein macht keine
Verhandlung zur Verhandlung gehören zwei
Seiten die ihre Lage so einschätzen dass
sie ein bisschen nachgeben müssen um ein
bisschen was zu erreichen die Lage haben
wir nicht Putin hat völlig klar gemacht
er ist überhaupt nicht daran
interessiert die Ukraine solange sie
Erfolg hat ist auch nicht interessiert
das zu früh das zu beenden und so
traurig die Botschaft ist ich glaube wir
müssen uns auf einen langen Krieg
einstellen und eher nicht nur noch
Monate sondern möglicherweise sogar
Jahre
das war eine Woche von nur schlechten
Nachrichten und die aller schlechtesten
Nachrichten kamen für die Ukraine das
waren nämlich die Nachricht dass sich
Russland auf einen ganz langen Krieg
einstellt den es beliebig verlängern und
aus ist die implizierte Botschaft dieser
Reise ist die Botschaft dieser Woche wir
wollen überhaupt nicht verhandeln wir
sind mit nicht zufrieden wir ziehen das
durch bis zum bitteren Ende und das ist
bei aller Motivation bei allen Erfolgen
der Ukraine im Moment die wirklich
schlechte Nachricht das im Zweifel
Russland den längeren Atem hat weil die
Ressourcen einfach größer sind es gibt
ein sehr verräterischen Post von
mitreden ich weiß nicht wer sich an die
noch erinnert der war Unternehmer
Präsident der analysiert die
strategische Lage von Russland und er
endet mit zwei wie ich finde
bemerkenswerten Sätzen rasiert
es russland hat gewählt und es gibt
keinen Weg zurück das heißt er hat damit
für diese russische Führung beschlossen
Login wir gehen den Schritt nach und das
ist mit Sicherheit kein Schritt in
Verhandlungen es ist immer ein Schritt
den die militärische Eskalation ich
fürchte wir werden noch sehr sehr lange
darauf warten müssen dass wir wieder
zwei Delegationen an einem Tisch sehen
ja sag mal relativ einvernehmliche
Botschaften die schlechte Nachricht dass
der Krieg sehr sehr lange dauern wird
das Zitat bleibt mir in den Ohren
russland hat gewählt
es gibt keinen Schritt zurück und Herr
von Marschall je größer die ukrainischen
Erfolge desto gefährlicher haben sie
gesagt wird die Situation weil Putin
umso unberechenbarer wird bedanke mich
sehr herzlich für diesen Austausch wenn
Sie hier in der ARD dabei sind dann
jetzt das Europa Magazin ansonsten
Presseclub nachgefragt in den sozialen
Netzwerken im Fernsehen bei Phoenix im
Radio bei WDR 5 danke bis hierhin
tschüss und lassen Sie es gut gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt wir starten in Düsseldorf
Klaus Hang ist am Telefon sie haben das
Wort bekommen in der Sendung
ja hallo in die Runde schönen guten
Morgen oder Nachmittag
ich habe eine Frage die sozusagen da
auch so ein vordiskutiert wurde es gibt
ja hier in Deutschland eher die
sogenannte German Angst gegenüber einem
möglichen Atomschlag andere Länder sind
da gehen da etwas lockerer mit um die
Frage ist man liest zwar ab und zu einer
Aufstellung wie viel Atomwaffen
sozusagen sich gegenüberstehen bei NATO
und eben auf russischer Seite aber man
weiß wirklich auch nicht genau was
passieren würde wenn das
word-case-szenario tatsächlich eintritt
das heißt die NATO als solche wäre ja
dann auch gefordert und man müsste
meines Erachtens auch auf dieser
ich sag mal
eigentlich unvorstellbaren für uns alle
unvorstellbaren Situation
tatsächlich konkreter eine Antwort haben
Frage ist angekommen Frau Wachs
beschäftigt sich sehr intensiv mit genau
dieser Frage was können sie herrnhang
Antworten genau also was sie ja
ansprechen ist eben das Putin eine
Nuklearwaffe also ein Nuklearwaffen
Einsatz gegen die NATO durchführen würde
und ich denke hier ist es wichtig zu
unterstreichen wir bewegen uns oder wir
leben seit Jahrzehnten eben in diesem
sogenannten Gleichgewicht des Schreckens
das heißt dass auf beiden Seiten eben
sowohl auf russischer als auch eben auf
nato-ebenen US Frankreich und
Großbritannien auf den beiden Seiten
enorme nuklearwaffenarsenale da sind und
dass wenn Putin ein Nuklearwaffen
Einsatz durchführen würde er damit
rechnen müsste dass er eben ein ein zwei
Shark erleben würde das heißt dass so
ein nukleber von Einsatz von unserer
Seite für für Russland für Putin quasi
selbst der Tod darstellen würde das
heißt Putin hat hier wirklich kein
Interesse russland hat hier kein
Interesse Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen das
heißt ich denke über dieses dieses
wirkliche Worst Case Szenario muss man
sich hier nicht weiter Sorgen machen
danke nach Düsseldorf
hoffentlich schließlich an
Code Heissler in Karlsruhe willkommen
schönen Sonntag
sie sind dran sie haben eine Frage oder
Beobachtung für uns ja ich wollte
einfach nur die Frage stellen warum
schafft man nicht die Möglichkeit
dass die ja das weite Land die Menschen
in diesen beiden Lande Alternative
fernsehquelle haben sprich
entweder ein geostationierten Satelliten
die Frequenzen dahin oder die Programme
darauf aufzuschalten oder eben ein
europäischen Satellit zu verschieben
einfach um den Menschen die Möglichkeit
zu geben
alternative Quellen zu nutzen und dann
frage ich mich wirklich warum läuft
Labor offener frei rum
ja das sind die zwei Fragen ja fangen
wir mit der ersten an die finde ich
hochspannend also ihre Vorstellung ist
der Westen reagiert in dem er frei
Informationen über Satellitenprogramme
nach Russland bringen ich weiß gar nicht
ob das technisch möglich ist was dazu
jemand was also ich gehe jetzt mal von
der Deutschen Welle aus die Deutsche
Welle die das ja seit Jahrzehnten
betreibt und die Deutsche Welle
ähm ist in Russland verboten worden die
Großmutter das Büro musste geschlossen
werden die Korrespondenten selber können
von Russland aus nicht mehr berichten
dass es ist kein Defizit an
Informationen da das muss man zunächst
auch sagen sondern es ist der ein
Defizit an willen da sich in den
verfügbaren Medien zu informieren es ist
nicht so dass man in Russland nicht an
Informationen käme es ist so dass es ein
bisschen Mühe kostet und diese Mühe ja
müssen wir die den Russen abnehmen sich
diese Mühe zu machen ich weiß es nicht
das wäre vielleicht eine Möglichkeit die
kann man überlegen aber am Ende kommt
für Bürger immer auch die Pflicht dazu
sich selber zu informieren ich möchte
Entschuldigung nur ergänzen wir reden
jetzt von der Stadtbevölkerung ich finde
Leuten in diesen weiten Land und wir
kennen die ja alle kann man nicht zum
Vorwurf machen dass es sich nicht aus
alternativen Quellen informieren Sie
brauchen guten Internetzugang sie müssen
diese vpn- haben um diese
zensurenmaßnahmen der russischen
Regierung zu umgehen klar man kann aber
jetzt auf die Leute zugehen ihr
katharinenburg Moskau St Petersburg kann
sein ihr braucht bitte schon andere
Informationen Informationen informiert
euch aus anderen Quellen der Großteil
der Bevölkerung und wir reden von
wirklich sehr sehr viel Millionen
Menschen hat eigentlich gar keine andere
Möglichkeit und wenn dann sowas passiert
wir bei der Deutschen Welle dann ist
auch die letzte Informationsquelle die
möglicherweise nach neutral berichtet
danke wir haben noch eine Frage im Raum
stehen bitte um kurze Antwort lavrov in
New York festnehmen warum darf der
wieder raus zum Flughafen und zurück das
hat halt einfach keinen Sinn dass wir
auf der Ebene umgehen wir wollen ja
weiter Kanäle offen haben und deswegen
haben Politiker die sozusagen unter
berufsmäßig Reisen haben dann eben auch
eine gewisse Immunität und das gilt
sowohl bilateral also USA aber die UN
sind ja auch so etwas wie außer
territorial das ist auch die Garantie
die in die USA gegeben haben und das
kann man nicht machen
später wenn diese Menschen kein Amt mehr
haben dann kann man das versuchen oder
aber nicht während sie noch im Amt sind
denn wir brauchen Ansprechpartner danke
wir gehen nach Berlin Ralf Pioch ist am
Telefon bitte auch guten Tag ja hallo
schönen guten Tag in die Runde ich habe
eine Frage was was wie würden wir denn
drauf reagieren wenn Putin jetzt sagt
naja meine
spezialoperation ist beendet ja ich
erfahre die russischen
eingezogenen in das Gebiet und fühle
damit trotzdem auf ja das ist eigentlich
die Frage
sie meinen in den Provinzen luans und
jetzt und den wo jetzt die
scheinabstimmungen stattfinden
ja ich nehme an die militärischen
Aktivitäten würden trotzdem weitergehen
oder
also hätte es irgendeine Wirkung wenn er
jetzt verhandeln wollte oder
300 Tagen ist also die Annektion ist
sozusagen rechtlich vollzogen und
er gibt der Bevölkerung russische Pässe
er versucht vielleicht zusätzlich Russe
in Russland dorthin zu bringen
da würde ich gerne antworten denn das
kennen wir aus der Ostukraine seit 2014
was dann passiert
wenn diese Territorien annektiert sind
heißt es sie bekommen Statthalter und
diese Statthalter sorgen dafür dass ein
Regime des Terrors installiert wird das
ist genau das was wir in diesen
sogenannten Republiken dann jetzt und
noch hans-gess schon gesehen haben in
den vergangenen acht Jahren wir sehen
das in den Orten in denen russische
Statthalter jetzt schon agieren dass
eben alle Andersdenkenden da
rausgeworfen werden bzw im besten Fall
fliehen können und im schlimmsten Fall
in foltergefängnisse kommen bzw
tatsächlich eben umgebracht werden also
das ist etwas was für die Ukraine
überhaupt keine Option ist danke Frau
Adler wir bleiben in Berlin Andreas
Steinmann hat das Wort guten Tag
wir sind zur Zeit zurecht die ganze
Berichterstattung zur Opposition in
Russland
und ich frage mich eigentlich mal gibt
es eigentlich auch eine Opposition die
parlamentarisch fundiertes auch in Kiel
war wenn in der Ukraine dann ist sie bei
Herrn sellinsky immer so dass ihr
sozusagen die Generalvollmacht hat das
Volk zu vertreten ich denke manchmal
bist du alles Volkes war als
schauspielert hat gibt es ja eine
Möglichkeit auch mal etwas anderes zu
hören als nur ihn und wann gibt es
eigentlich Parlaments und
präsidentschaftsverein
zwei Fragen bitte
also es gibt sicherlich auch
Opposition in der Ukraine also das die
Ukraine ist ein demokratisches Land also
das ist nicht zu vergleichen mit den
Verhältnissen in Russland wo es eben
zwar diese diese System
Opposition gibt die aber eben keine
wirkliche obsition darstellt und
jegliche oppositionellen Kräfte eben in
Gefängnisse oder Arbeitslager kommen das
heißt da sind die Verhältnisse in der
Ukraine gänzlich ich habe die Frage auch
ein bisschen so verstand ich weiß nicht
ob irgendjemand am Tisch in den letzten
Wochen in der Ukraine gewesen ist ich
habe die Frage auch so verstanden ist
das was selinsky ausdrückt die Stimmung
von sag mal 80 90
95% der Menschen im Land
zu sagen es hat demokratische Wahlen
gegeben es gibt würde jetzt turnusgemäß
2023 Wahlen geben unter
Kriegsbedingungen wird es diese Wahl
nicht geben daran ist nicht die Ukraine
Schuld sondern daran ist Russland Schuld
und es gibt einem breiten
gesellschaftlichen Konsens der besagt in
dieser Situation hält das Land zusammen
das ist nicht so dass es keine
Opposition mehr gibt aber die Opposition
hat für sich entschieden sie stellt
jetzt ihre innenpolitischen
Befindlichkeiten zurück das ist nicht
die Zeit um sich im kleinen klein zu
verlieren wenn es um das Überleben des
Landes geht aber die Opposition ist da
sie ist extrem lebendig sehr munter und
die Macht dem Präsidenten durchaus das
Leben schwer in normalen Zeiten danke
Herr Steinmann wichtige Frage und
wir gehen nach
Osterode am Harz Lutz Brinkmann guten
Tag
ja
sie sind auf Sendung wir sind gespannt
auf Ihre Frage oder Beobachtung ja ich
möchte mal sagen der Scholz hat doch
völlig recht indem er sagt wir machen
keine Alleingänge ja wir müssen keine
Angst vor Putin haben aber wenn schon
solche Dinge dann sollte man mindestens
Europa mitnehmen
das ist so wir wissen als die Einheit
kam da haben ganz viele Europäer
fürchterlich Angst gehabt dass
Deutschland stark wird
oder sollen Sie jetzt bitte auch
mitgehen das wäre etwas was der Scholz
mal machen könnte und könnte dann
vielleicht als erster sagen so wir
machen das jetzt aber wir Europa nicht
Deutschland von Deutschland wird
ziemlich dumme Debatte geführt dass wir
alles gleich mal ganz schnell machen
müssen Herr von Marschall ist schon ein
bisschen unruhig
diese Frage hat ja zwei Seiten nicht
natürlich wenn sie sagen wir sollten
nicht mehr tun als die anderen Europäer
wir sollten ihn nicht enteilen mit
unserer Unterstützung der Ukraine aber
ist das denn so ist die Debatte in
Europa so dass die Deutschland die
deutschen viel zu viel tun und alle
anderen die Polen und die Balten und die
Franzosen bitte mal langsam nicht so
schnell dass es viel zu viel sondern
Deutschland steht ja gerade umgekehrt im
Ruf das ist weniger zu tun bereit ist
obwohl es das wirtschaftlich und
politisch stärkste Land in Europa ist
und deswegen hat auch dieser Scholz Satz
nur gemeinsam der hat zwei Seiten er
kann nicht mehr tun aber er darf eben
auch nicht weniger tun als die Europäer
insgesamt wollen und bei den
Panzerlieferungen sind ja genau diese
Lösungen im Moment im Gespräch dass
nicht die deutschen allein liefern
sondern Konsortium mehrere europäischer
Staaten gemeinsam diesen deutschen
Panzer liefert also den Niederländer mit
und so weiter und dann sind wir im
Geleitzug und das soll man nur sehen
also es funktioniert nicht nur in der
Einrichtung so wie sie die Frage
gestellt haben sondern es funktioniert
auch in der anderen Richtung dass wir
nicht weniger tun sollten als andere
Herr brinkmann
sollte ihnen noch mal das Wort geben
also sie haben ihre Wahrnehmung gesagt
Herr von Marshall hat seine
entgegengehalten ja
der Scholz der Macht nicht er kann ja
vielleicht
etwas deutlicher Europa
er kann ja sagen so Europa wir gehen
jetzt vor ja aber er sollte nicht
alleine machen und insofern hat der
schon recht danke dass Sie das
formuliert und so klar gesagt haben ist
ihr Blick drauf gehört auf jeden Fall
dazu Gruß nach Osterode und in Marburg
ist Karin Schwalm in der Leitung
verschleim bekommen schönen guten Morgen
der Krieg eskaliert das ist völlig
richtig was wir eigentlich der Westen
dafür dass dieser Trick endlich aufhört
wir schauen immer noch nach Russland sie
haben heute morgen nur diskutiert was
Putin macht Scholz war gerade in New
York da hat anschließend der Präsident
der Außenminister von Mexiko und auch
der Präsident des szenegal vorgeschlagen
was möglich ist sie haben sich angeboten
eine Vermittlerrolle aufzunehmen warum
wird das von uns nicht aufgegriffen wir
könnten so viel tun um wirklich diesen
Krieg zu beenden ich sehe hier keine
diplomatische Offensive des Westens wo
ist das friedenswege und ich finde es
auch schön sie würden mal Friedenstauben
in ihrer Sendung einladen Leute die
diese Version wirklich vertreten Eugen
Drewermann Frau Krone Schmalz und so
weiter und so fort es ist mir zur
einseitig was die uns hier bieten das
tut mir wirklich leid vielen Dank ja
vielen Dank dass Sie das so formuliert
haben und frag mal unseren Berliner
Korrespondenten Stefan glaube jeder der
hier am Tisch sitzt wünscht sich den
Frieden und zwar am besten in zwei
Sekunden die Grundfrage was man
diplomatischen Bemühungen erreichen kann
da muss man natürlich irgendwie sofort
wieder nach Russland gucken sehen Sie es
hat ja irgendwie auch große Bemühungen
gegeben es hat ja Verhandlungen gegeben
von beiden Seiten wir haben das in März
und im Aprilia gesehen die sind kläglich
gescheitert bei Russland natürlich nicht
bereit ist ohne Vorbedingungen zu
verhandeln wenn die Bedingungen von
verhandeln heißt wir behalten all das
was wir uns erobert haben dann wird es
schwierig mit diplomatischen Initiativen
ich gebe Ihnen Recht dass wir zu wenig
darüber reden was wir jenseits das
militärischen tun sollten und ich glaube
ehrlich gesagt einer der großen Jobs der
europäischen Führer wird sein die
Europäische Union zusammenzuhalten wenn
man sich so ein bisschen anguckt dass in
Italien gerade gewählt wird dass man
möglicherweise da Rechtspopulisten an
die Macht bekommt dass man in Ungarn
Gefahr läuft dass diese Sanktionsregime
verlassen wird dann würde ich sagen
lassen sie uns darauf konzentrieren
lassen sie uns weitermachen man muss
gucken dass man mit einem Block Russland
gegenübertritt letzter Satz dazu alle
wollen Frieden aber wenn Russland nicht
bereit ist zu verhandeln dann können sie
sich glaube ich entschuldigung dass ich
das so salopp sage auf den Kopf stellen
Frau Schwalm danke wichtiger Aspekt und
ich glaube diese Sendung macht ganz gut
deutlich die einen fragen was kann man
mehr für Verhandlungen tun die anderen
Marken unserem Gästebuch fragt wie
realistisch ist es dass die
Bundesregierung in den kommenden Wochen
ihre Position zur Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern ändert und den Weg dafür
frei macht wer hat da eine Einschätzung
hat natürlich eine Frage der Zeit jetzt
eine Frage der Zeit dass wir das tun
genau ja ich würde auch hier meinen
anderen Kollegen zustimmen dass es
sicherlich eine Frage der Zeit ist also
es gibt unterschiedliche Ideen eben das
Konsortium das eben Deutschland quasi
vorangeht und zusammen mit anderen
Staaten in Europa die eben also
Deutschland hat eben
diesen panzertyp den es eben liefern
könnte und der eben auch in anderen in
anderen Staaten in der NATO vertrieben
sind das heißt hier fühlte sich
Deutschland mit anderen Staaten
zusammentun und also die Ideen sind da
und ich denke zumindest haben wir das
bisher gesehen bei dem Verhalten der
Bundesregierung dass es immer eine Frage
danke für mich Frau Wachs muss den
Schlusspunkt setzen die Nachrichten
warten danke für den Austausch an diesem
Tisch tschüß und schönen Sonntag aus
Köln
[Musik]